it's 5:35 in the morning you should
never wake up in darkness if the Sun
isn't out that's a sign that whatever
you're doing is not worth it I just got
my car pretty tired I've been a couple
these are for and I thought they're
really fun sir I told Jen and Maci and
Ryan from the testings the test friends
but I call them the testes because it's
a great guys I invited them to come to
this party to see what they think of it
I think I can do this
go we're gonna try and dance it's
actually crazy there's so many cars and
so many people and I don't understand
why it is 6:30 5:00 in the morning we're
gonna dance and then we're gonna go to
work it'll be [ __ ] awesome
tired I feel it okay I don't really like
dance parties at night yeah don't like
dancing at all
I don't know it just feels weird like
before why do people do this that's like
the only people who wake up early to go
dancing I like beautiful people and
Henry this is probably like the weirdest
/ silliest thing I've ever done on a
work day it's a Tuesday Daybreakers
started about a year and a half ago in
New York and then it's almost our
one-year anniversary in LA it's a way to
get people out of their normal routine
to have fun in the morning and then go
to work and we change the world this
gathering is just about the energy that
we create together to supercharge our
day our week our life it's not serious
it's just fun for everyone face paint
and body paint on us it was pretty rad I
feel like it looks kind of cool so I'm
into it I got a coffee today but I feel
great I had weird watermelon rind drinks
yeah I had watermelon juice instead of
coffee cuz I wanted to like challenge
myself like do I need coffee no I'm
gonna be energized but dance and guess
what I am I just want to say that right
now I'd normally be just getting up and
feeling super groggy and I feel
incredible right now instead it's just
like yeah even be getting up for 20 more
minutes you would think like it's light
out so people are judging but because
it's light out I think it's just come as
you are who cares have a good time
people really accepting in there we
joined a dance line and there were these
like awesome dancers teach those dance
moves I learned this thing yeah no I got
it I'm I got this I'm good
I definitely wouldn't describe this as a
rave it's almost like a workout class in
the morning but with dancing it seems to
be a more genuine positive time like I
did not see a single person like grind
up on a girl and like try and do that
except for right now now I'm trying yeah
we tried to make it happen earlier it
didn't work blanketly describing it to
someone be like there's this really
crazy sober 6:00 a.m. dance party sounds
really weird it is really weird but you
should try it because it's also really
fun I like I'm no great I think I got it
enjoyed it more than you did I you know
what I think what it is is for me you
have to be able to dance you have to
like be not self-conscious at all and
I'm not sure I'm there necessarily when
I'm sober I saw a new side of Henry
Goldman today I'm like I did not know he
had both lose he's busted him out it was
pretty rad it takes a special kind of
person to be able to get up very early
come here dance party and absolutely
yeah this type of person I'm dancing
Sobers [ __ ] at 6:30 in the morning
you